hey friends we are getting closer and
closer to iPhone season which means Iowa
17 will be officially released to
everyone not just the public developer
beta so I've been using iOS 17 now for a
while and I'm just going to show you my
top five favorite features there are a
bunch more and I did do a further
in-depth video if you want to check that
out but now that I've been using it for
a while this is what I've been liking
the most and I'm not gonna lie it is the
stickers so in iOS 17 you're now able to
make stickers out of photos and live
videos live photos not well they're
technically videos but they're live
photos so you make a little live photo
here so I'm gonna go in and I'm going to
turn on live photo my photo is on the
interesting thing about doing these is
you kind of have to start the action
before you hit record because the live
photo records shortly before you hit
record and then after so it's it's kind
of an interesting thing but once you get
it you get it I'm gonna start waving
so now we're gonna go into my messages
we're going to go into the stickers and
here's one that I've made before and I'm
gonna go in I'm gonna make a new sticker
it's so easy that it it almost just
hurts in my soul as like a designer how
incredibly easy it is to do things that
used to be very processor intensive time
intensive and now we just it's just like
that that's it like we go like this
and I send it it's so easy I freaking
love it
I can even go in here and make this even
bigger
I love it they're so great now what's
also interesting is you can add
different types of features so you can
make these stickers look a little bit
different so this one I'm just going to
take a regular photo
add effect so you could do like a little
outline you could make it into a comic a
little puffy sticker or even a shiny
sticker which I think that I like the
shiny sticker so we're gonna go with
that and that's going to be my shiny
sticker it's just cool because you can
do this with any photo so let me find a
picture of my dog I'm gonna make him
into a sticker add that right on top of
hers look at Maddie he's walking this is
just adding so much more fun and
interactivity to iMessage and I'm also
really excited about the new keyboard
the predictive text it's just felt so
much smoother so hello Jenna I am
testing
the keyboard it just feels better like
it just feels smoother the autocorrect
isn't trying to correct things that it
shouldn't it's hard to explain until you
actually use it I didn't think that it
was going to feel different but it does
have a different feel to it also it is
kind of weird because I sometimes type
with like two fingers like this like wow
look at me type digital touch I actually
forgot about that oh my God does anybody
remember this
that was like a thing I don't think I
don't really know does anyone use that I
forgot about it so this is something I
actually can't demo here but I can't
wait for this it is the ability to leave
a video voicemail when you FaceTime
somebody they don't answer but now you
will actually be able to leave them a
video voicemail and I think this is such
a cool idea because obviously if you're
calling someone you are able to leave a
voicemail speaking of voicemail this is
also one of my favorite things is the
voicemails now will Auto transcribe so I
hate listening to voicemails I also
don't like listening to voice memos
because I don't know I get distracted I
don't know what someone's saying I need
to be able to have like an account of
what they're saying but the
transcriptions on the voicemail I think
is key because you can also choose to
pick up or you can just continue letting
them leave that voicemail and you can
just read it as they're talking which is
pretty awesome they have an updated
thing called Contact cards which allows
you to customize your contact card so if
you make a phone call to somebody
customize your photo and what's really
cool is if you do have I guess multiple
contacts like if you're at a business
event you can have a business contact
and you can also have a personal one so
maybe you want to give people your phone
number or if you have a business number
you might want to give them that
separate card and it's really great
because you can choose which information
you can share with people
even if you don't want to share
information with them you can decide to
leave off what you don't want to share
so here's a few that I made already you
can adjust the font your photo the
colors so we're going to create a new
one just so I can show you how this
works we're going to go into our photos
I'm gonna find a photo of myself oh look
at this I've already got like a ton of
pictures that it suggested so this is
cool
um oh my gosh I miss Hawaii Hawaii is a
wonderful place so here we go look at me
just chilling at the beach we're gonna
change this to a different font I kind
of like that one can pinch to crop so
maybe we'll Center myself I can preview
my poster and I can choose that the next
time that someone calls I needed a prop
for this next one
this next one is called standby mode you
may have seen this at the Keynotes where
they were talking about it so basically
if you have a stand and it charges your
phone at the same time and when you put
it like this uh horizontal it will
automatically switch to standby mode and
now this is showing some photos this is
from south side of Pittsburgh that's my
friend Susie and we can scroll through
these that's a terrible photo
um we're gonna just not use that one
this is a nice photo from a hike that I
went on and Maddie there he is I'll even
use a baby at Short ears now you can
swipe through and you can get different
watch faces watch faces
um this reminds me of the standby mode
on the Apple watch so I said watch faces
this one's fun I added a bunch of
widgets you can have reminders you can
also swipe on each one of these to
change it to be something different so
depending upon what you want your
nightstand to look like that is
something that you can do something else
that I haven't been able to demo yet is
airdrop over the internet I use airdrop
for absolutely everything like I airdrop
photos I airdrop videos content from my
phone to my computer from my computer to
my phone and it is one of my favorite
things ever but if you've ever
airdropped someone before and you've
kind of went out of range of their phone
it fails but now what happens is that
content will then be uploaded to the
Internet so then as the other person
walks away they can connect to the
internet and that will continue to
transfer when they're back in reception
so you don't actually have to be near
them anymore and that is gonna be so
awesome for events and just even
transferring files and photos here even
in the office like if I decide to go
outside like I don't have to worry about
something stopping air dropping like
it'll just magically work so there's so
much more than iOS 17 but those are a
few of my favorite I feel like I could
probably sit here all day talking about
it but before we know it my friends it
will be here and we will all have access
to it if you do have a compatible device
and then it's gonna be iPhone 15 time I
actually just I don't where did this
year go I have no idea I would love to
hear from you guys though what are you
looking forward to most in Iowa 17 and
what is something that you're most
looking forward to in the new iPhone 15.
thank you guys for watching don't forget
to like comment and subscribe and be
sure to hit the Bell to be notified when
I post new videos because it is almost
Tis the iPhone season and you guys know
that is my favorite time of year so I'll
see you here bye